just a warning that this debate contains
images and language that some viewers
may find distressing
the holocaust words which should send a
chill down
all of our spines around six
million jews and many others were
systematically killed
in multiple death counts throughout
world war ii
these innocent people were forced from
their homes
stripped of their belongings separated
from their families
work to their death used for human
experiments
routinely beaten shot at point-blank
range
and executed in gas chambers it is
almost beyond
comprehension hundreds of thousands of
ss soldiers were complicit in these
murders
whether directly or indirectly and in my
view
they all have blood on their hands
a pitiful number of prosecutions have
followed against these soldiers
many of which have seen their
convictions overturned and for that
there is no excuse
the ss soldiers today are frail old men
and a current trial against bruno day
saw a 93 year old former ss soldier
been wheeled into a juvenile court many
are proclaiming that he should not be
prosecuted
simply due to his age but that is wrong
age is just a number and it is the duty
of a civilized world
to ensure that these heinous crimes do
not
go unpunished however much time has
passed
[Music]
much as in the previous conversation we
talked about jane moore and the sun
i want to talk about another colonist
and whitaker who writes for the daily
express who spoke and i
wrote about this and said essentially
that this trial is more about
vengeance than it is justice and i i
really can't agree and i'll explain why
after we hear
from what the lawyer who's acting for
bruno de stefan vortecamp
had to say mr day the guard didn't join
the ss he was simply dressed in ss
uniforms without ideological training
and then he had this job he knew the
prisoners were not in there because they
were criminals but they were in there
for anti-semitic racial and other
reasons that were not legally correct
and he felt felt sorry for them but felt
unable to free them
in 1944 at the age of 17 how would you
have acted
would you have tried to instigate an
uprising or would you have tried to
complain
so that's what the lawyer says and to a
degree he's right
because had he complained he probably
would have been shot
he would not have saved a single jewish
person and nedita's family might have
been shot
but currently regrettably we live in a
time when anti-semitism
across europe is on the rise while i
don't think this man should face he's 93
i don't think he should face 10 years in
jail or whatever
he actually has to be brought to justice
because it's a message that goes out to
people who in germany are involved in
anti-semitic
shootings on jewish holidays and lastly
not this man but the people that he
guarded and the people he worked with
had no problem herding people in their
90s into the gas
chambers so i don't think it's a problem
ushering a 93 year old
interface a legitimate and fair trial
it's yeah i i know nazi hunters say we
owe it
um to the victims to to bring continued
prosecutions but and i've read quite a
lot about what survivors
from from the holocaust have said and it
is very interesting that their view on
this
is not what you would think there you
know for them justice is not about
seeking
legal retribution it's about seeking
answers
to questions that they have it's about
they're motivated by
shining a light on unresolved neglected
crimes
in in a way that will when i say educate
hollywood it's about holocaust education
so this can never
happen again and there's been lots of
talk about at this late stage
70 years down the line that perhaps one
of the solutions would be
restorative justice initiatives where
you bring together
um if the victims left and if there any
there's any perpetrators left
you bring them together in an attempt to
deal with the offence
and the aftermath and and the argument
behind this is
that if you do that you gain knowledge
and information
about crimes for which there are no
paper trail it
makes it harder for the holocaust
deniers to exist and to live
before i go to family i just want to
correct you because not it's not all
survivors feel like that summer
survivors
yes survivors yeah we should be guided
by what they think that's what i think
we're talking about essentially well i
mean you talked about
uh what you can learn from essentially a
nazi
former former nazi i don't think we need
to
free somebody from justice because we
need to learn that nazism might be a bad
thing
this is so much more complex than that
but i mean
the idea that we're going to grant mercy
to somebody because they happen to evade
justice for for so many years that is
so wrong the fact that he managed to
manage to stay stay free should not be a
reason for him to continue to stay
have you read about what he said because
so have you read what he says his part
and all of this was
he said he was a god he said he never
discharged his rifle he
there is no actual evidence against him
that he hurt
anyone now i'm not making excuses for
guards and concentration camps i'm just
saying
haven't we come a long way over the past
70 years where you can just think about
this
if you tie someone down while somebody
else kills them or does whatever to them
do you know you do that
no the point if you're guarding this
place you're making sure they don't
leave so if you if you're guarding the
place to make sure they can't leave and
then they're killed you are
participating in that crime now
the fact that he um has managed to evade
glasses for so long just i mean for this
long
every single second that he hasn't been
in prison is an injustice and an insult
to everybody who suffered
under him and they have known for 40
years
they've known he was a guard in this
concentration camp for 40 years
i mean the problem with this is it's
almost impossible to have a rational
discussion
because the crimes were so obscene was
so
awful and you know i still have friends
who's
who when you talk to them their
grandparents the great
all died in in these camps and i don't
i mean in some ways thankfully this
generation is dying
and that there won't be many more of
these but i agree entirely
with you michelle i don't i don't think
there will be a trial
the trial will take on the things you're
saying and i hope it's a fair trial
but in the end of the day these anyone
who was involved in what an ss uniform
who was involved in these camps
if you could there are thousands you
said earlier who who have never been
were never bored i want this particular
person to end his life in jail
that for me would be what i would see as
proper justice
the part that he played i couldn't care
less if he was the
so what are you working on this thing or
holding the gun to me and not just to me
in 1969 there was a ruling that said
unless you've been directly involved in
the the killings you can't be prosecuted
that was actually then subsequently
changed
in 2011 and that change was implemented
when oscar groening who people might
remember was the accountant or the
bookmaker of auswitch
when he was sentenced when he was in his
90s if you
are there and you are involved and by
the way in terms of lessons learnt from
history
please make sure that we remember the
amount of genocides that have been
happened since this and by the way if
you if you look at things like um
myanmar and the rohingya muslims that's
currently still happening in modern
day so people haven't learned let's talk
about other tribes you know
the bosnian war you know when milosevic
and carrijest and uh
they they were brought before the hague
quite rightly and
and shamed and punished in the eyes of
the world because these people
were leaders of a genocide they
masterminded
the genocide my only argument with this
guy is
let me ask you two a question if you had
been a 17 year old
and and you had been told by an ss
officer that
you had to be a god would you say no
knowing that saying no
probably meant you'd be shocked how i
would respond to that sorry fear makes
people do a bizarre thing
well how i would respond to that is that
you're looking at the end
product the nazi regime didn't start
with death camps all over the place
chucking people into gas chambers and
pits
that was the product after lots and lots
of incremental bad things happening and
if people had
stood up at this stage in the press in
the process it probably wouldn't have
even
got to the level of the camps 17 year
olds should have
fairly wonderful same question to you on
that on that point
honestly i i probably would have run
away um i would because i would know yes
at your point that if i tried to take on
the nazi regime i'd probably be killed
immediately so i'd probably run out of
probably run away
run away i do think it's important by
the way we listened to a holocaust
survivor yeah
my mother my younger brother
my younger sister was sent to the
crematorium
and we saw not far
from the place when a chimney fire came
out
and this terrible smell
it smelled like burning flesh
and we asked for people who were already
there
what sort of factories here and they
said
it is not a factory
that they burn your families
that literally send shivers and i was i
went to austrian berker now a couple of
weeks ago
and it really anyone that's not been you
should go and experience
and really understand the atrocities and
as i've said you have to prosecute these
people
to make people realize you cannot treat
people in this way just because of
racial or
creed or colour differences and the fact
that even today as i've already said we
still have a genocide ongoing
shows me that lessons have not been
learned michelle thank you the story the
significance of which
we shall never and probably must never
forget
you're watching the pledge on sky news
and up next i'll be swapping my suit
for a sombrero
[Music]
you